[MUSIC PLAYING]
OSCAR MAHONEY: I
think the first time
I heard about the
Humanities Sequence was
when I got the literature in the
mail advertising this program,
talking about it as
this intensive course.
DANIEL GRANBERG: When I
got accepted to Princeton
and got my package
with all the stuff,
I remembered the pamphlet, the
HUM pamphlet, in particular.
And I think it said something
along the lines of hungry
for knowledge.
And immediately I was
drawn toward that.
DENIS FEENEY: The
Humanities Sequence
is a yearlong introduction
to the toolkit
that you need to understand
the building blocks
of Western European tradition.
We begin with Homer
in the first semester,
and we end with Dante at the
end of the first semester.
And then we pick
up the beginning
of the second
semester with Petrarch
and carry through
to Virginia Woolf.
YELENA BARAZ: I gave the
opening lecture on Homer,
and I introduced the
students to Homer.
In very general terms, I
talked about oral tradition
and the origins of the text.
It really is a team effort.
So for instance, this
semester our group
includes an ancient
philosopher, a classicist,
a medieval historian,
a Dante scholar,
someone who works
in late antiquity,
and a comparative
literature professor.
All of us have specialties
but we are also
learning from each other.
And going to each
other's lectures
really creates a kind of flow
where people will pick up
on each other's lectures and
each other's texts in ways
that they might not
otherwise think of.
And it goes along very well
with the student experience
because we're experiencing the
course alongside the students.
And we are remembering
things from lecture
that they are also
remembering, so it
creates a kind of
trajectory that
really is the distinctive
feature of the course.
CRYSTAL LIU: I remember
at the very beginning,
I was kind of
apprehensive because I
felt like I didn't really
have any background
in ancient texts.
And I went to Professor
Baraz and asked her,
am I expected to know
some Latin, some Greek?
Do you think that not having
those skills would hinder me?
And she said absolutely not.
We don't want you to feel
like that's the case.
We want you to learn.
That's exactly why
this course is here.
ESTHER SCHOR: When
I saw the syllabus
for the first time four
years ago, I was intimidated.
And I realized that
you're not going
to address every page of
these books in detail.
The point is to have
a sense for what
strikes you, what's important.
JAMAL JOHNSON: I
think really being
able to sort of historicize
some of the ideas that
are prevalent in the thinking,
not just of white males,
but of people from a
diverse range of backgrounds
is something that was
really valuable for me.
CLAIRE ASHMEAD: All the
thinkers we look at,
again because they're
asking questions
that are so central,
end up being
very useful tools for thought
and for change and for argument
for people everywhere.
ESTHER SCHOR: Well, we
hear a lot about difference
these days.
We hear about what
makes people different.
Ethnicity can make
people different.
Social class can make
Whether your parents
went to college or not
can make you different.
And we have a lot of
testimony about the difference
that difference makes.
And the question that
arises in this course
is what is this talking back to?
I mean, what is this
idea of the human that
is being questioned here?
What we're finding is that
we're listening to human beings
across time and we're
hearing difference
across the centuries.
DANIEL GRANBERG: After
reading "Antigone"
we went and saw
"Antigone" performed.
And that was definitely
an experience
because it wasn't
expected, I would say.
It was performed in
a very different way
than one might see
it being performed
when reading the book.
And there were
things that really
made that an experience that
was able to help me, at least,
connect "Antigone," the
play, to our modern-day life
and how this is
related to me today.
CASSIE RODRIGUEZ: One
thing that I really
enjoyed was going to the Met.
We went on a Greek
and Roman tour.
And as you walk through the Met
and you look at different art,
and being able to use textual
support for your analysis
and stuff like that, and
facilitate a connection, I think,
is the best part.
BENJAMIN MORISON: Going to
the museum you can actually
be in touch with the object.
You're looking at the objects
that the ancient Greeks were
also looking at or that the
Romans were also looking at.
And the skills that
we've given the students
at reading text and
deciphering details
and putting things into context —
And I think it really
gave the students a chance
to see that this isn't
just a dead culture that's
on the page.
This was a living culture
where the texts were performed,
but the texts also
made an impression
on the decorative
arts that would
have been surrounding the
people that lived in those days.
OSCAR MAHONEY: So
we had a small event
and we invited all
of the first-semester
students in the HUM Sequence
at the moment, the freshmen.
And they brought in some
alumni from the program,
people that had taken it that
were currently sophomores,
juniors, seniors, to talk a
little bit about what they
thought about the program
and why they thought
it would be a good
idea to continue
taking into second semester.
To have a foundation to be
able to walk into a seminar
and read a text,
whether it's something
that I've ever been
exposed to or not,
and kind of get those nuances
from other texts in the past,
start to see the threads running
through the Western tradition
history and be able
to talk about them
and add something
new to discussion
that I would have otherwise
been completely blind on.
Most of the things
are a reflection
on what you guys have
already read and experienced
in the first semester.
So this is why I really wish
that I had taken the first.
But if anybody, I think
there are one or two of you,
haven't taken the
first, I absolutely
recommend that you
take the second
because you're going to find
yourself thanking yourself.
Graduates of the HUM
program have the opportunity
to go to either Greece
or Rome on a fall trip.
The great thing about it
is that it's completely
paid for by the HUM department.
CLAIRE ASHMEAD: I
had the opportunity
to go to Greece,
which was amazing.
So that was the fall
break of my sophomore year
after I'd completed
the HUM Sequence.
And going to the origin
of Western culture,
because the HUM Sequence starts
with Homer and "The Iliad,"
that was really wonderful.
I think, not just because it's
a little bit of a pilgrimage,
because you get to
see, this is the place
that inspired these thinkers
that are the foundations of why
I think the way I do.
The HUM Sequence and
the HUM community
is something that's
known on campus.
It's something that
other professors respect.
tells them something
about who you are when you
tell them that you've done it.
JAMAL JOHNSON: You
sort of, just grow
to be a more
questioning thinker.
Someone who's
equipped with the tool
set to really to dig deeper
and trying to find answers
to some of those questions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]